James Matthews from Sky News flown what
other debris have you found and have you
found any trace of those who were on
so this is an incredibly complex uh
operating environment on the sea floor
over two miles uh beneath the surface
and so uh the the remote operating
vehicle has been searching and it is
highly capable and we've been able to
classify uh parts of the pressure
chamber for the Titan submersible let me
refer to one of my undersea experts here
Mr Paul hankin to talk about the nature
of some of the debris
thank you Admiral
so essentially we found uh five
different major pieces of of debris that
uh
told us that it was the
remains of the Titan the initial thing
we found was the nose cone which was
outside of the pressure Hall
we then found a large debris field
within that large debris field
we found
the front end Bell of the pressure hole
that was a first indication that
um
there was a catastrophic event
shortly thereafter we found the
a second smaller debris field within
that debris field we found
the the other end of the pressure hole
the the AFT and Bell
um
which was basically the comprised of the
totality of that pressure vessel we
continue to map the debris field and as
the Admiral said we will uh
do the best we can to
fully map out what's down there